بعد اشهر على هجوم مضاد انتهى بالفشل
باعتراف القوات الاوكرانيه اجرى الرئيس
فلاديمير زيلينسكي تعديلات جذريه في صفوف
قواته المسلحه وما ان اعلن اقاله قائد
الجيش فاليري زوجني من منصبه واستبداله
بكسن سرسكي حتى طالب قيادته العسكريه
الجديده بوضع استراتيجيه لهزيمه القوات
الروسيه يجب ان تكون خطه عمل واقعيه
ومفصله للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه لعام
2024 تاخذ في الاعتبار الوضع الحقيقي
لساحه المعركه الان وافقها خطه عسكريه
جديده تبعث الامل في قلوب الاوكرانيين من
جنود
ومواطنين لكنها لن تكون مجديه وفق الرئيس
الروسي الذي اختار في اطلالته النادره مع
الصحافه الغربيه المذيع الامريكي الشهير
تكر كارلسون المقرب من دونالد ترامب ليؤكد
ان هزيمه روسيا في اوكرانيا
مستحيله كانت هناك صيحات واصوات تدعو
لالحاق هزيمه استراتيجيه بروسيا في ساحه
المعركه برايي هذا الامر مستحيل ولن يحدث
ابدا هزيمه روسيا مستحيله وفق بوتين لكنها
ممكنه بالنسبه لحلفاء كياف وخاصه بعض
الديمقراطيين داخل الكونجرس الامريكي رغم
انهم لم ينجحوا في تمرير مشروع لرصد اموال
اضافيه لاوكرانيا بعد دعمها باكثر من 110
مليارات دولار